what's up guys i'm lisa foiles here with
gamespot and the day has finally arrived
a video game Disneyland as i call it III
2014 is about to kick off i am here live
outside the Los Angeles Convention
Center the beautiful huge giant
convention center III III is in there I
downtown LA I've always thought kind of
smells like cat pee it does today but
it's made so much better it's so much
easier to stomach with all these
beautiful video game banners decorating
this entire place over there under that
tree if you can see you've got assassins
creed unity The Witcher 3 o beautiful
girl you're just the sexiest Silver Fox
and evolve sonic boom over there giant
ps4 banner of course they get the
biggest banner in the whole place
yesterday you guys got to watch the
press conference is and today today was
Nintendo's two talked all about the
amazing games were going to see today
there were some awesome announcements I
like mass effect 4 we got some
confirmations of games we knew we're
coming of course there's going to be
another tomb raider hopefully we get to
see that today and then we got some
amazing surprises that I'm still going
crazy for we got a little big planet 3 I
know I feel like a child saying that but
I'm so excited for that game and also
you should come with me because I don't
want you to get hit by a bus see I'm
looking out for my team and also grim
fandango is coming to the ps4 and the
vita my favorite game of all time i am
so excited harnes are going off it's
crazy out here people are lining up to
get into the expo hall inside is even
crazier than out here you can just kind
of like feel this excitement I'm jittery
I'm excited come that I want to show you
more come come this way cross the street
here looking for cosplayers I know
they're here they're probably hiding
from me but well we'll find some good
ones for you over here over this way
there is a giant live painting happening
those guys have been up there those lil
scandals what's up guys painting this
like cool PlayStation mural I would love
to take that home I'm going to see if I
can just like steal that at the end of
the show
but yeah like you know like I said last
year's e3 all the press conferences it
was all about the consoles and this year
we get to see the games that actually go
on those consoles I mean this year is
all about the games we've got the
hardware it's about the games this time
so be sure to tell me what games you
guys want me to see I'm going to be
heading around the e3 floor all day in
fact at 3pm I have a live camera
following me for an entire hour so be
sure to tweet me tell me where you want
me to go I'll be like your sim I'll be
like your sim character you know or like
your virtual pet you just tell me where
you want me to go and then I'll go I'll
clean up after myself though you don't
have to do that be sure to stick with
gamespot all day we have incredible
incredible coverage of all of III and
I'll be I'll be right there with you
guys the whole time got some awesome
stages Chris Danny everybody you love
tweet until your fingers are raw with
the hashtag gamespot III and as you can
see I don't know they're giving away
stuff over there oh oh that's like a
food truck play a video game themed food
truck oh I am so excited you guys be
sure remember like I said hashtag
gamespot III make it happen
you